to the screen so I'm I'm the Cushman
sink I'm delighted to be here and I'm
actually I feel really fortunate that my
talk is right after Dan's because I'm
gonna be giving a complimentary story to
the foundational story he presented so
we're gonna be working in two
probablistic programming from the frame
of application systems that are aiming
to augment human intelligence and the
context I'd like to set for that there's
of course been a tremendous amount of
excitement over industrial AI systems
especially recently but the problems
that those systems solve are all games
that kids can learn to play so they have
very narrowly defined sets of rules it's
easy to tell who's winning or who's
losing and while it may be hard for a
kid to get as good as you know a top
performer it's easy to get them to play
the game and that flexibility is of
course in comprehensively faster than
the flexibility of the AI systems right
like alphago can't parse English let
alone play jeopardy
yeah I don't mean to say that any kid
can trivially learn how to play chess or
go or jeopardy but over many ages you
know and another feature of all of these
domains is that the nature of human
knowledge that's needed to do well on on
them I mean especially the the the
classic games is is quite circumscribed
and I want to contrast that with the
types of problems we've been working on
from an applied perspective so my labs
been working with the Gates Foundation
for a couple of years trying to help
them do empirically grounded policy
advocacy in their malnutrition practice
so the Gates Foundation funds primary
data collection and a network of
partners that represent many different
fields of expertise and questions
they're interested in include questions
like well let's say they fund the
malnutrition intervention in Bangladesh
should they try to pitch a particular
government in Africa to adopt the
results are the results relevant on what
basis what if they're costly to adopt so
you know how to make an empirically
grounded case and and these are really
difficult problems there are no
well-defined rules there's clearly data
that's relevant there's also a lot of
human knowledge that's relevant and
something that was a surprise to me as a
computer scientist interacting with
these communities is that the the sort
of the state of understanding is is is
it's quite loose right now so you know
for example when it pertains to growth
stunting due to malnutrition so will a
child have you know an abnormal growth
trajectory due to growth insults in
early childhood kids that have actually
similar nutritional environments have
very different outcomes so it's not just
as simple as give everybody you know
more food overall
maybe returning this problem over the
course of the talk so that the technical
tools we've been bringing to bear on on
problems like this all come from
probabilistic programming and for the
purposes of this talk the frame I'd like
us to adopt for what Provost ik
programming is is you know an emerging
field at the intersection of modeling
and inference programming languages and
systems software where probabilistic
programming systems
unlike traditional programming languages
like C let's say but a little bit more
like languages like let's say sequel let
you put in modeling assumptions and ask
questions but unlike languages like
sequel they let you get back answers
that may be incomplete or uncertain and
you know sort of over the over the
course of development of the field many
different types of languages have been
proposed and prototyped growing from the
lens of either basic AI research or
statistical relational learning or
statistics in some cases a bunch of
different user communities I'm mostly
going to be focusing on picture and
Bayes DB which are two domain-specific
proble stick programming languages under
active development at MIT right now in
my group and I'll spend a little bit of
time talking about venture which is also
which is our attempt to ask the question
is it possible to build a
general-purpose proble sztyc programming
system in which you could maybe
implement these other probabilistic
programming systems faithfully but a key
feature of all the languages that we've
been working on is they're designed to
be read and written by both people and
machines and that'll come back again and
again throughout the applications okay
so let's start with picture which is a
probabilistic programming language for a
computer vision
so the the frame for picture is to
formulate computer vision problems as a
kind of inverse to computer graphics so
what do I mean by that well computer
graphics is this wonderful success story
of computing which has given us tools
for going from symbolic descriptions of
scenes so here I'm showing a source file
in the Padre language which is an open
source ray tracer few images and the way
we go from these source files to images
as we kind of parse them and turn them
into data structure as representing
scenes and then maybe pixel by pixel at
least in the simplest sense solve an
equation which tells us you know sort of
what's the color of the pixel by
simulating all the light bouncing off of
all the objects this is a nasty integral
like evaluating a marginal probability
density it's often done by Monte Carlo
techniques but this can be done on very
complex worlds in real time so there's a
very old proposal in visual perception
actually going back to Helmholtz that
posits that the visual system can be
understood as the inverse of optics so
in picture what we've been exploring is
kind of a computer scientist version of
that proposal which again has a long
history in in computer vision so let me
give an example so let's say you wanted
to solve the following problem you're
gonna be given input images of faces and
you want the machine to be able to
answer questions like how would this
face look if you rotated it and lit it
differently so here I'm showing inputs
and outputs to a particular picture
program so the input faces are shown
here and then here I'm showing pictures
rendering of a 3d model inferred from
that face with novel poses and novel
lighting and here's an example of a face
that's not in frontal view this column
is showing the 3d reconstructions just
you can kind of get a sense of sort of
what the best fit model was to the input
data that's then being rotated and
rerender so I'm going to use this
example to give you a little bit of the
mechanics of what one kind of
domain-specific problems to
programming system looks like so here's
an architecture diagram for that
application there's a scene generator
which is the stochastic program that
generates random scenes those are fed
into a differentiable renderer that's
actually quite approximate and rough it
doesn't to produce photorealistic faces
and then those are compared to the image
data by this funny differentiable
comparator which I'll give you a little
bit more detail on later and somehow
we're gonna go from the image data to
inferring the scene and then transform
it feed that into a more realistic
renderer and then get back the novel
image of what did this face look like so
here's the inference process unfolding
and people asked how long this takes the
the default inference algorithm takes
you know tens of seconds maybe a minute
for this application so it's not
suitable for real-time use spanning
means but this is the first prototype of
the language so here we're watching in
front so unfold slightly accelerated so
you can see how the reconstructions
evolved over the course of sampling so
like the initial guess doesn't look very
much like the input face which is shown
on the left here but then pretty quickly
it kind of gets into the ballpark and
then it's fine-tuning the the model
and that's done by this page of code so
picture this prototype of picture is an
embedded language in Giulia and there's
a scene generator up here a call to a
renderer all the stuff is built using
off-the-shelf components from computer
graphics which are easily available
within the Giulia environment and then
all the meta programming glue to
actually construct the inference engine
is kind of folded into these calls you
can see here we grab this trace I'm
going to show you more about this stuff
later yeah I'll show you that in a sec
that's the comparator so we use deep
learning in picture so it's not just the
massive okay oh well so sure sure what
do I mean I mean when I use MATLAB then
I write a short matrix times vector you
know a script that multiplies some
matrices let's say you know there's the
whole linear algebra subsystem right so
so what I'm trying to highlight is the
application specific code is very small
and the neural net here is not
application specific it's a generic
comparator that we use for all the
applications in that paper and there I
guess the citations on the previous
slide right so and I should say we first
prototype this picture architecture and
venture back in 2013 so we did like a
smaller scale version and then picture
was the domain-specific kind of
enhancement of it last year
so this scene basically has a mesh a
texture map for the face and then camera
and lighting information and that course
wants this code block it's about a
hundred parameters and then the
rendering of that in some pose might
look like this if you ran this whole
thing multiple times you might get a
bunch of different faces with a bunch of
different orientations and lighting now
we're going to compare it to the real
image by using the latent features
produced by a convolution convolutional
neural net that's been trained on real
images so this is an optimization some
of the picture programs work without it
other picture programs require it for
people who are curious I can go into the
details the intuition is if you're
building a generative graphics program
where the appearance match to the real
images is very important then you don't
need this but if instead you're doing
like the poses where you don't to have
to model all the things somebody could
be wearing on their shirt you need some
way of kind of approximately inferring
and integrating out your uncertainty
over appearance and that's what the
neural net is doing so unlike the
earlier work and Inventure the picture
inference engine has a bunch of bunch of
bells and whistles to make this work
efficiently enough so for example it
doesn't use single sight metropolis
Hastings like Dan mentioned but it uses
a combination of gradient search and
elliptical slice sampling which takes
advantage of automatic differentiation
to calculate the gradients of various
core functions that include the whole
renderer as if a people familiar with or
who aren't familiar automatic
differentiation it's a technique for
tracked ibly getting you know gradients
basically through functions that are
defined by complex code with data
structures and control flow it's a nice
meta program originally developed in the
computational science community picture
also makes use of learned Helmholtz
proposals for fast kind of bottom-up
initialization of the scene so there
we're really drawing inspiration from
kinect microsoft's kinect interface
where one of the ways one of the core
inference engines in kinect was a set of
random forest classifiers that were
trained on poses that were generated by
graphics offer so they would generate
random poses
and then trained classifiers on the
depth data that you could produce by
just rendering depth images from those
randomly generated scenes so in the
picture paper we call those Helmholtz
proposals and there's just a simple
trick for doing that for a broad class
of computation trace structures that was
what one of the tricks that was used to
make the connect real-time and that's
part of the scaling story of the
performance engineering story for
picture so some of our colleagues like
Noah Goodman and at Stanford News and
the student student genuine Richy have
done some really excellent work taking
this general framework and also applying
it to art problems in art and graphics
this is one my favorite examples so that
so the task here is arrange some
cylindrical blocks such that when you
light them from the side it casts a
shadow that lines up with this contour
this is again like a few hundred
dimensional parameter space so not
thousands or you know millions but a few
hundred
the next steps on picture for us
pictures being developed in
collaboration with Microsoft including
some of the visions like push meet Koli
who is one of the the vision leads on
connect and with David Wingate who's
also speaking here and we're really
focusing on developing a version that's
more tightly integrated with venture and
has a runtime in Lua and tera that's
going to be more scalable for work in
aerial robotics so you know 3d models of
scenes that drone cameras can see
because this feels like a fruitful place
to bring structured prior knowledge to
bear on interpreting data from the
visual world okay so that's picture we
just pause for a moment any questions
about picture yes generative at receive
influence great questions so so so let
me let me reframe slightly there's a
whole class of generative models for
images that are being built by the deep
learning community Geoff Hinton has done
a few with Russell Akutan of before
generative adverse ale networks those
got more play recently there were a few
recent papers fact actually TJ's
Kulkarni the PhD student who did picture
went to deep mines after graduation to
go work on deep learning for generative
image models to work with Jeff actually
well first Jeff and then and then off to
deep mind so
so the way to think about that is take
this architecture right this
architecture is saying we're going to
use human understanding of how to
generate images from computer graphics
to provide the skeleton of our
generative models and then we're going
to use programming technology and
technology from computational physics
and statistics to take code that
represents that understanding and then
like convert it into code that can do
inference so this is a pretty different
approach than trying to directly learn
functions that go in Reverse although
you can see right in principle any
neural net approach to learning in
versus in vision could be positives as
alternate paths for implementing this
Helmholtz proposal box here so another
way to put it is at least from our
thinking it's it's more like those types
of research represent ways of developing
components that you could integrate into
custom inference strategies for picture
programs as opposed to somehow
alternative proposals and actually part
of the project of picture I think over
the next few years is going to be to try
to argue that that I mean a question one
could ask right is you know in computer
vision when people are successfully
applying deep learning what's going on
in their heads to enable them to come up
with the network architecture so nobody
knows but one class of proposal that I'm
interested in is the possibility that
you could view some of the successful
deep learning architectures for 3d
vision as you know essentially Hardware
compiled picture programs you know where
you're using machine learning to just
learn very good proposals that simulate
the output distribution of some more
complex probabilistic program
any other questions about picture
okay okay so I wanted to spend most of
the the time in this talk talking about
Bayes DB which is a prolific programming
platform for data analysis that's also
the most mature from an applied
standpoint so for example they need to
be builds on components that were
actually commercialized in my first
startup and we just recently about a
year ago started another startup that's
commercializing a product that's been
spired by Bayes DB so we've a little
clearer idea of how to kind of make it
work in practice than we do for some of
this other stuff although it's still
early days so the problem that Bayes DB
is trying to solve you can think of like
this so you start thinking about like
this so so so in both science and
business empirical inference so when
users have you know people have
questions they want to answer on the
basis of empirical data there's a
consultative workflow that's that's
often used to answer those questions
we're a statistician or in industry
these days somebody with the same skill
set who's higher paid called a data
scientist basically structures and
cleans the data builds models and then
develops apps and predictors and they
they have to they're responsible for
doing a lot of Quality Assurance like on
the data itself but also interfacing
with people who can check whether the
answers are reasonable and whether
end-users actually find the resulting
systems or answers useful this process
works best when the data is complete
uniform clean and cheap and one of our
collaborators at JP Morgan for example
says a key ingredient as the data
scientist has to have a lot of empathy
they sort of to be able to understand
many different perspectives to succeed
at these consulting projects
and we've been doing some applied work
in in what we call the medium data
regime so not data from uniform
processes like you know click streams or
you know the outputs of physical sensors
or you know logs of transactions and you
know the machine economy but but you
know data that comes from non repeatable
events where you have convenient samples
maybe not random samples and real-world
problems from from science and business
and here the data is often sparse it's
not uniform it's not clean and it can be
very costly to acquire more data so so
it presents challenges that that I think
are worth spending a moment on
so the first point and this is something
that that that I only really began to
appreciate by talking to people who did
data analysis and in business is that
there's actually something of a
replication crisis for data analysis so
many of us have heard about a
replication crisis in psychology let's
say some people are arguing that there
is one in medicine but but there
actually is evidence that there is one
in data analysis so there's a beautiful
paper where people actually tried to
assess the repeatability of data
analysis by giving it fixing the data
set in questions they took a data set of
soccer games and a question about racial
discrimination in a particular call in
soccer and they had 30 teams
internationally try to answer the
question
and the results were all over the place
so you know 20 teams found a
statistically significant positive
effect and nine teams observed a
nonsignificant relationship and the
paper kind of shows like all the
confidence intervals for the teams that
could report them it's pretty grim and
as a result you actually see at the at
the sort of end user level and the
executive level a lot of distrust of
data analysis so there's some recent
surveys talking about c-suite executives
discounting data analysis they don't
understand and I think it can be
tempting certainly it's tempting to me
you know we give my technical background
to attribute that to maybe like a lack
of comfort with quantitative thinking
but but I but actually don't think
that's the case in fact it turns out
that in life sciences and banking the
CEOs in those industries which really
exist their existence in their modern
form depends crucially on the
development of statistics as a
discipline they have the highest
distrust in data and analysis and I
actually find that reassuring in a way
right so what what can we try to do
about this from a from a technological
perspective so let me give an example of
the first I felt kind of kind of maybe
meaningful real-world application of
Bayes DB that that led us to start to
start an empirical which is the the new
start up so I was at a Gates Foundation
meeting and I met a clinical researcher
working on diabetes so his
goal was to see if you could develop a
blood test that you could give you know
to say people over 40 that would
construct some multivariate proxy for
the degree of insulin resistance in the
in the subject so insulin resistance is
normally measured by a painful costly
time-consuming procedure that requires
that the person to fast go to the
hospital and basically get hooked up to
a feedback system that fights their
body's ability to regulate glucose and
insulin it's painful enough that there
apparently I gave this talk I'm at a I
gave this example rather at a I had a
data science conference recently and
someone the audience mentioned that
their spouse had received advice on how
to fake the results of this test so like
people will exchange that information
because it's sort of so uncomfortable
and then also the lifestyle changes you
have to enact afterwards are
uncomfortable right so you know if if
you could improve screening that that
that would be significant and so this
person I met Adil from Chalmers
University in Sweden was involved in a
clinical trial a multi-centered clinical
trial across Europe which had produced
among other things a sample of 250
patients and 400 variables for those
patients 50 of them are clinical
indicators you know height weight blood
pressure this kind of stuff and then the
other 350 were concentration levels of
various compounds you can measure from
the blood test we wanted to see hey is
there some multivariate proxy for
insulin resistance oh and and all these
patients had undergone this painful
procedure via clinic that was vetted to
have high quality reproducible results
and when I met him he was actually he
had written this study off as a failure
the stats team had said it was
underpowered it was in the middle of
another trial that had three times as
many patients and just to calibrate cost
of data acquisition this spreadsheet
cost about six million euro to collect
the data for
and the follow-on trial was you know
about 20 million so it's like
it's a very different regime than the
one that let's say we hear a lot about
at the intersection of machine learning
and distributed systems you know where
there's some instrumented social process
that provides a near infinite stream of
data so the frame for for what we did
with Bayes DB was to kind of use Bayes
DB as a virtual data analyst so we can
understand what we ask the data analysts
to do in English so we said all right
Bayes DB so I did this in about half an
hour the next day after getting the CSV
file I said used the data from the CSV
file he gave me and there's a variable s
ID 1a which is the ID variable so please
ignore it and null values in the data
are going to be represented by periods
so Bayes DB accepts a combination of
sequel and various probabilistic
languages which I'll give you some more
examples that the next thing we said is
please build an ensemble of models that
might be suitable for exploratory
analysis so like quick and dirty and use
whatever data types you think are
reasonable on the basis of the data
alone because I have no understanding of
diabetes or the data set so guess the
statistical types for all the variables
create a meta model using a baseline
method called cross cot which I'll talk
more about initialize 64 models and
analyze for eight minutes
then give me a sketch of the probable
dependencies between all the variables
and finally tell me which 15 variables
most probably predict insulin resistance
she has spelled that in in be equal the
Bayesian query language that's the
interface to Bayes DB as estimate the
dependence probability of the columns
call that probability of dependence with
m'aimes the variable indicating insulin
resistance and order by that variable in
descending order a limit 15 so show me
the fifteen variables was the most
evidence from the data that there's some
predictive information does that's
nothing about the strength the sign of
the relationship anything like that just
evidence for its presence so this is the
table we got back and for me there there
was something interesting about it which
was you know a lot of the results you
can check with common sense so there's
of course fasting insulin fasting
glucose cholesterol two measures of
blood pressure fat mass body mass index
waist and hip measurement so things you
might expect from a common sense
understanding of a metabolic disease
that at least in extreme cases is kind
of an obvious physiological presentation
at least you know with some of the side
effects yeah so that's because we're
only using 64 models and so this is
basically discretizing the confidence
and so these are Monte Carlo estimates
of posterior probabilities in the
presence of a dependence slightly more
formally their estimates of the
probability that a model based estimate
of the mutual information between those
two variables is greater than zero and
which what you're seeing is with 64
samples that's not just the quantization
of that posterior estimate great
question
and it turns out that menos which was
one of the metabolites that was flagged
in this list my colleague had been
arguing for as relevant for giving a
prognosis for diabetes for about five
years on the grounds of mechanistic
quantitative models so from his
standpoint what happened was he gave me
a CSV file
I hadn't clearly knew nothing about
diabetes and in about half an hour I was
able to repeat back to him some stuff
that was validated by common sense or
medical understanding which correlation
would miss many of these cases and give
him interesting new candidate knowledge
like just hypotheses to look at so I
don't think this proves anything but
this was the first time for me I felt
able to go from empirical data about the
world to useful knowledge using rigorous
methodology and for you know I mean
otherwise my experience learning
modeling and statistics has been the
more I learned the harder I find it to
trust empirical arguments yes
that if you try but I thought this is
some of the same data yes yes yeah
that's right I'll talk a little bit
about that and there's a bunch of papers
online that that go into that question
more it's a central it's absolutely an
essential question for understanding
safety for tools like this so you could
ask the part of it all address in this
talk is you know what's this cross cat
baseline method so the basic idea is
we're gonna find a way to model high
dimensional data tables and we can't
just use something like mixture modeling
so here's a data matrix and here's the
data matrix sorted according to the
clusters found by a mixture modeling and
clustering algorithm and one thing you
can sort of see is that with with
mixture modeling you know some of the
variables maybe turn out to be kind of
clean but then some of them still look
pretty noisy and that's because you're
using one set of clusters to explain a
whole lot of variables and probably
there are many different ways of looking
at the data that would be needed to
explain different subsets of variables
so the baseline method in Bayes DB was
called cross cat and there's a jam LR
paper on it online that that has all of
the technical details but the first
version of it as a research project in
cognitive science goes back to 2006
which addresses this problem I'm not
gonna say too much more about it I'll
just say
if you want to get an understanding of
the hypothesis space that cross cats
exploring so in the sense of the traces
Dan was showing earlier if you had a
four by three data table what cross cat
basically does is it puts down a prior
over model structures like which
variables probably depend on each other
and then which cells probably depend on
each other for each subset of variables
and it's a semi parametric Bayesian
prior so it includes edge cases like
every cell in the data has its own
idiosyncratic parameter or there's just
a simple set of parametric models that
are sufficient to explain the data and
we use standard tools from nonparametric
Bayes so it's like a hierarchical
factorial combination of Jewish life
processes the particular methodology we
happen to use to set up a prior over
this space and then inference proceeds
by a Monte Carlo scheme that basically
shuffles the rows and columns of the
data stochastically exploring this space
of model structures trying to put you
know variables together that appear to
have predictive information and then
independently clustering the rows with
respect to each group of variables so
one partial answer to question of
multiplicity is there are no tests being
performed when you run that query you've
actually built an ensemble of joint
probability models you have a separate
question of how safe is that process but
then conditioned on that you're just
querying the models using information
theory so there's actually no multiple
testing happening at all okay so I'll
just say a little bit about another
application domain for Bayes DB so let's
take a look at a database of satellites
yes is it some kind of work or on
graphical model structure that we can
impose on your data yeah that's right so
what it said it's serving the same
function as that but it's not literally
using graph structures so in one sense
you could say Bayes net structure
learning is known to be a difficult
problem both in practice and in theory
somehow we have to solve a problem
that's analogous to that to go from data
to model structures and the way we're
doing it is we're just not literally
searching the graph structures we're
searching this kind of induce
partitioning of the data like
essentially equivalence classes of
graphs in a certain sense how much you
trust one thing that's right that's a
that's right
so the generator yeah so yeah that's
right yes good so
so I think I'll skip the satellites
example we've done applications to lots
of databases there are lots of queries
you can ask Bayes DB but I'll just show
you a slightly more complex
probabilistic program than the diabetes
example so I apologize that the screens
getting cut off I suggest you look at it
on the monitors so here we're showing
how you can build a model that doesn't
just use the baselines
this cross cap thing but actually
overrides the models for various
variables using standard techniques so
for example here we're overriding the
generative model for launch mass try
mass power and wats perigee and Apogee
in a database of satellites that's
public using factor analysis and we're
exposing the loading factors and you can
also do things like override other
variables with regression or random
forests to classify orbit type so you
have this interesting hybrid model
specified by about a page of
probabilistic code that combines the
data with domain understanding about
statistics and machine learning but you
can go farther and actually integrate
Kepler's laws using something that looks
more like church if you're reasoning
about satellites you know it might seem
natural to put in things we know about
orbital mechanics so you can alter this
generative model to plug in a
probabilistic program that's written in
venture that actually puts in Kepler's
third law and learns a clustering model
for the exceptions from Kepler's laws in
the data and that takes about another
page of probablistic code to do now once
you have that you have something you can
query that's combining the empirical
data the results from statistics and
phenomenological summaries of causal
knowledge in the form of the
probabilistic program okay and then you
can run queries like I can say infer a
variable that tells me the category of
how big the exception is from Kepler's
laws so is it a negligible exception
with a small deviation from Kepler's
laws or is it an extremely large
exception
so this is a case where I'm now querying
an implication of the data and the
modeling assumptions it's just not
available in the data set itself and
Bayes DB gives a framework now for
integrating and successively refining
modeling assumptions in light of both
additional data and additional
structured knowledge okay so I'll close
by just saying a little bit about
venture so and in here I'm just really
gonna give pointers so we're actually
teaching a class at MIT a semester long
introduction to probabilistic
programming and one feature of venture
we're using is that the interactive
front-end which is there's an embedding
into an IDE Python notebook but it lets
you combine the languages from Bayes DB
with ventra script and in principle we
can integrate other problems take
languages like stand or web ppl venture
also supports multiple representations
of the core objects and probability
theory so not just simulators samplers
like dan was talking about but inventor
you can also represent density functions
and package them together so it actually
lets you use that constructs from
programming's this fixes a limitation of
Church we're in church all random
objects were represented as samplers
here you can represent them using the
fuller set of constructs from
probability theory and there's a thesis
available online and master's thesis
describing venture that's the best
reference that I would recommend for
this audience and finally in venture
inference is programmable so dan
mentioned this notion of these execution
traces but he was talking about how
you'd implement an inference engine for
a probabilistic language well in venture
ventures kind of like a lisp but where
those traces are a first-class data type
so you can write venture programs that
trace other programs and then modify the
traces and that's the programming model
for inference programming that lets us I
think leave the confines of a purely
declarative model that's unlikely to in
my opinion to scale
okay so just to wrap up I've been
talking about total stick programming in
software but it's important to realize
that you know I mean Dan talked about
the compute ability of sarcastic
inference right
he's an Bayesian inference more
generally so for us in our in our lab
these software languages fit within the
the context of a software stack that
includes other ideas from systems
programming and user interfaces and a
slowly emerging set of proposals for
hardware for this kind of computation
and it even more slowly emerging set of
proposals for theory and programming
knowledge and they're a bunch of
citations on you know on this slide I'm
going to post the slides online for
people who are interested in following
up but the question we've been asking
ourselves is is it possible to construct
an end-to-end stack of computing
abstractions for this type of
computation and I think there's a reason
to want to do this
so the Gates Foundation is trying to use
Bayes DB ultimately I mean the
aspiration is to use it as a medium for
enabling coordination and collaboration
by policy advocates domain experts field
researchers and statisticians you know
they all have different types of
knowledge that that somehow need to be
captured in the system and this is an
instance of a kind of applied computer
system in which the software is acting
as an assistant to a human supervisor
you can imagine this in many different
domains I've shown examples of a few of
these in the course of this talk
actually but where the supervisor is
using probabilistic programming
potentially to give guidelines questions
and hints and getting back in complete
solutions with some representation of
uncertainty and then supporting this
kind of close collaboration between
people and software I think is going to
continually push the capability
boundaries of problems to programming
and may motivate the development of some
of the surrounding stack of four
natively Provost at computation great
thank you so much
over there is one pressing question big
one question
okay we have been your time is a great
litany to as private party